I'll put me out of your misery by the
way just to just to make you feel a
little better I can't remember I mention
this so forgive me everything's new and
I'm sorry reintroducing everything for
the first time so this is like my third
time service to you
sorry my bad one of the things I did
over the holidays was I went to Canberra
to this thing called the National
mathematics of school did I mention this
I did right okay so one of the things
that we got to do was as teachers we got
to sit in on some of the lectures for
Miss Universe in the maths so it's me
crazy stuff which like I struggle to
remember so it was really kind of in a
sort of painful way nice to remember
what it's like just have devoted to you
what's going on like I I'm sort of like
three three whiteboard behind him I
think I understand that let me just
introduce something so if you're having
trouble I emphasize it to you ask me
questions like I know that sometimes
I'll say no what you think about me but
actually I'll answer so here we go
this'll be the last thing to do okay
very last thing I told you this is the
clue right this is the clue now you
actually because of all your work here
and here you know everything you need to
actually evaluate this thing
right and this is just the definition of
the ellipse okay so let's pick a point
like say PE okay so when you sit in this
distance and we know what that point is
and the other distance which is this
perpendicular yeah okay now in order to
work out what that one is this one looks
a little problem for this we'll need the
equation in general form where we and we
don't have it there right now how I
rearranged it what do I need to do to it
what ways to I'm in discussions with it
first step
x e that's okay now what move the a over
probably helpful to chuck in a 0 for the
Y right - hey ok there we go now I'm set
okay get rid of those watch it unfurl so
for the point 2 s which is this okay
just the distance formula right so X
minus a squared plus 1 just Y squared
isn't it because you're going to there
can do from right hand side there's the
eccentricity
what's the perpendicular distance this
is why I've written that in general form
with the 0 and everything absolute value
the x + 0 y minus a what's on the
denominator square it a T squared + 0
Smith fine ok so much you're going to do
that a what's this whole thing it's just
the this is looking good ok now what we
would do I guess we would square
everything ok that gives you this I
might as well do this expansion because
I'm going to need to eventually x
squared minus 2a the X Y s plus a
squared e squared plus y squared ok what
am I actually squaring here the e x- a
all squared so I'm gonna end up with
let's see B squared x squared minus 2a X
plus
a square good okay these are always
signals for you that you're probably
doing something right okay all right now
hold on before we actually finish off
what direction should I go in because at
this point I can simply find a variety
of different ways what do you think I'm
gonna end this thing should be the
equation of the whole ellipse I already
know what the equation of the whole of
this is right it's gonna be heading
towards something like that so probably
what I want to do is get on with all the
X's and Y's overheated and get all the
constants over here okay all right so
where are my X's I'll go next squared
here and an e squared x squared there so
x squared minus X so far so good
Y squared there that's in the right spot
what's the sweaters that belong it's a
closer so I'm gonna cut it over let's
see a squared plus a squared okay what
was that now once should factor I see
yeah x squared what do I have plus y
squared which I do key take out the a
squared
now what remember I'm trying to go I'm
trying to get one on the right-hand side
right so I guess I should divide through
not just by 1 minus e squared
I should divide through by the whole one
on the right hand side yeah
sir over here x squared 1 minus e square
and on - yes plus y squared on a squared
minus B squared I did all of that so the
right hand side would become 1
cancel cancel that's good but we have a
problem this is not what we expected it
to be or is it what do you do now so so
the reason why say ok what would we
wanted these but we've got no B's the
reason why is because we never had beat
now I can bring them in let B squared
equal this guy because it has to be
everything else is in the right place so
this must be what B squared is